thank you
welcome to innovators Hive here at
Google Cloud next we have tens of
thousands of developers joining us in
person Google Cloud next is our Flagship
event and innovators type is our
Flagship experience for Developers
[Music]
Developers for joining us for three key
reasons networking with fellow
developers and Google experts learn
about the latest and greatest Google
Cloud technology and then finally have
fun along the way
[Applause]
[Music]
we have key personas focused on data
devops app Dao productivity Etc also a
combination of various key experiences
for developers fly cup challenge that
developers of any skill level can
participate in now Hands-On learning and
immersive learning is a key part in
educating developers about all the
learning resources that we have and the
process to get certified as well as
recertified on RQ Technologies we also
have communities both internal to Google
as well as external communities and
developers get to learn from Champion
innovators who are the x-course and key
Technologies so it's super exciting to
be here
next 23 has been an incredible
experience just connecting with
developers from all over the world we're
super thrilled about next 24 in Las
Vegas
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign